bass it's his first start this year his
first start in fact since 2012 when he
was pitching for the san diego padres
all the work out of the bullpen this
year so freddie freeman is the atlanta
hitter
freddie freeman unloads on the very
first pitch and cracks that to deep
right center and it's gone one-nothing
atlanta
freddie loves hitting down in miami and
i said no surprises you see that chip
he's seen that pitch before and he
jumped all over it
hanging slider
his 18th home run braves strike first in
the first
and don mattingly
looks on as
his club has a bullpen game on its hands
and their bullpen
has given up the game's first run i mean
that's where you want that pitch
a little bit down you see where he gets
that full extension
and when you get the lick of the lips
from freddy you know it's gone raven hit
a get me over fly ball
he was ready for it wasn't he yes let's
see if charlie morton jeff can finish
his first half with a bang yeah see that
good start to the season for charlie
this first half and you'd love to see
him get that eighth win marta six home
runs and 18 rbis this year
wow there's a
that good curve ball bird he was talking
about in the pregame you see that just
he he can turn it into two or three
different ones and you see this one
starts right over the middle of the
plate and then just slowly dies it's so
tough
and that's the thing he can throw
another curve ball to marty next time up
and it'd be a completely different pitch
so two off two down here's jesus aguilar
one-two pitch on the way line in the air
to deep right field going back to cunha
the warning track squares up and makes
the catch as he back pedals to the base
of the wall so down they go one two
three in the bottom of the first inning
a really good start for charlie morton
in the braves one nothing atlanta first
opportunity for the braves for the
runner at second or third base tonight
it comes with two outs in the top of the
third again the runners lead freeman and
albe's the pitch missed inside bases are
loaded so riley works his way back from
a two-strike count and abraham almante
is coming up a couple of grand slams for
almonte who awaits the 1-0 pitch
and it's popped up right side
aguilar jazz chisholm is under it he
catches the pop out and the braves leave
them loaded in the top of the third
inning
so morimondo finds a way out no runs one
hit no errors and three left braves have
stranded four through two and a half
innings one nothing atlanta as we start
the fourth inning dansby swanson will
lead things off against sean moramando
they shift against swats and only
aguilar on the right side and the o2 is
taken for strike three called he's
caught looking for the first out here in
the fourth
and more mondo gets him on the fastball
in the inside corner that is now his
sixth strikeout on his fourth strikeout
actually on the night and doing a really
nice job mixing his pitches and keeping
these brave hitters off balance kevin
smith to the plate strikeout victim his
first time on 2-1 smith hot smash to
short nicely gloved though by miguel
rojas across the first and it's a one
two three fourth inning nicely done sean
morimondo so he's pitched three
scoreless so shawn moromondo's a pitch
away from escaping another mess here he
stranded a runner in the second inning
he left the bases loaded in the third
worked one two three fourth now two
braves aboard with two outs in the fifth
inning riley walked his last time up
that was against mourimondo struck out
in the first that was against anthony
bass two balls two strikes two outs and
two braves on
called strike three
on the outside corner
and more armando strands of pair in the
fifth charlie borton protects a
one-nothing lead one-two count
and a swing and a miss back-to-back
strikeouts for charlie that's four in
the game
had a good start to the miami
fifth inning and one going here in
inning number five
bring up the number
straw came out looking inside corner
beautiful pitch front door two seamer
man you saw panic couldn't even pull the
trigger on that pitch armundo got a good
sacrifice down he has only played
appearance one ball in those strikes and
the fastball is chopped on one bounce
right back to charlie
horton's throw to first in plenty of
time and it's a three out three down for
charlie morton who has now retired five
in a row and at the end of five complete
in miami it's the braves one and the
marlins nothing so this would be a fun
matchup acuna versus bender ronald one
for three tonight
and acuna got hit with a breaking ball
and he takes a couple of steps out
toward the mound
that was a breaking ball
i know ronald's tired of being hit by
the marlins
but the last thing bender wants to do is
hit him in a one-nothing game and again
jeff this was a breaking ball
yeah i think that's why you're seeing
snit and ey look you got a young player
he's you know
look he's emotional he's animated that's
why what makes ronald so good when he
plays but yeah i mean this was an off
speed pitch and hopefully ewi is telling
him if anything get to first steal
second steal third get him back that way
now ozzy back hitting left-handed braves
looking for their first hit for the
rider in scoring position
serve toward left that's going to get
down and go to the wall it's two-nothing
atlanta ozzie on his way to second he'll
pull up there and at last the braves
break through
revenge is sweet for ronald lacuna jr he
scores the second run it's two to
nothing well look at ozzy's chip taking
a page out of freddie freeman's book
knowing the ball's running away i'm
gonna see it deep in the zone and look
at him
just a nice easy swing down the left
field line
gets a double and as i said this is the
best revenge
you had that all-important run this is
what the braves have had trouble doing
tacking on runs you got your pitcher out
there dealing right now you need nine
more outs and now you give them a little
bit of breathing room and looking for
another big one here's austin reilly
and riley third that's a fair ball and
down the line it's three to nothing
all the bounces and breaks starting to
go atlanta's way and riley's thinking
about three he's on his way he's gonna
belly flop in with a triple what do they
say about awakening a sleeping giant
perhaps that's exactly what that hit by
pitch is done
yeah you see that two seamer and he's
able to keep this ball just fair down
the line and then you can tell how far
they were playing him in the gap the
fact that austin was able to turn that
into a triple and as we said the tack on
runs chip that's something
braves have not been great at this year
that they were last year so 42 rbis for
riley that's his first triple well the
braves send six men to the plate they
pick up two runs man the braves leading
the marlins three nothing in the bottom
of the seventh
big pitch coming up right here
3-2 on the way
swung on and missed strike three
fastball right on by the swinging bat of
jesus sanchez
[Applause]
came through at 96 miles an hour charlie
just rared back and let it rip
and that's his seventh strikeout
so two men out here's arcia
that's crack to left and he will pick
him up
an ambush job swanson strolls home it's
four to nothing
booking doubles for the braves bats in
the eighth inning and those add-on runs
man are they a long time in common well
garcia is an aggressive hitter
oaker kind of just threw a little get me
over slider he puts a great swing on it
atlanta's been wearing out that left
field corner
it's an easy score for swanson dansby
had that double in the eighth inning
you'd love to see him get one more base
hit right here driving that run rares
back and fires and it swung on and
hitting the air to right field toward
the line laying out for a great catch as
duvall or did he short hop it
austin
isn't sure he went ahead and scored
and apparently it is a base hit for
dansby swanson and rbi and a
five-nothing lead now for the braves
well it's jesse chavez coming on to
pitch the bottom of the ninth inning
braves trying to shut out miami it's
five to nothing and the 2-2 pitch on the
way swung on missed he struck him out
what a perfect punctuation for a great
pitching staff performance today from
the atlanta braves charlie morton seven
innings of two-hit shutout baseball luke
jackson a scoreless eighth jesse chavez
a scoreless ninth inning finishing with
a punch out